[Música]
en Sao Paulo Brasil el candidato a la
presidencia y ex jefe de estado Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva protagonizó su
primer meeting masivo de Cara a las
elecciones de octubre Lula continúa
liderando las encuestas Pero bolsonado
ha ido acortando la distancia
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
suspendió las órdenes de captura contra
los delegados del Ln en Cuba un avance
en el restablecimiento de los diálogos
de paz entre el estado colombiano y la
guerrilla
compareció ante la justicia el ex
procurador general de México encargado
de las primeras investigaciones sobre el
caso Ayotzinapa y considerado el
artífice de la llamada verdad histórica
Bienvenidos a esta edición dedicada a
las noticias más destacadas del
continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos en Brasil el ex presidente y
candidato del partido de los
trabajadores Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
celebró en la ciudad de Sao Paulo su
primer acto de campaña multitudinario de
Cara a las elecciones de octubre Lula es
Favorito pero el actual presidente Jair
bolsonaro está repuntando los detalles
con Laurel
Lula da Silva frente a sus seguidores de
Sao Paulo en este primer sábado de
campaña oficial para el sillón
presidencial de Brasil el ex presidente
y candidato izquierdista lidera La
carrera en la última encuesta de
datafulla con un 47% de los sufragios
frente al 32 del actual mandatario y
candidato a la reelección
ultraderechista Busca acercarse a los
sectores A fines de Lula como lo muestra
su nuevo programa de asistencia social
enfocado a los más necesitados
este pueblo Aquí es muy sabio este
pueblo sabe que quiere este pueblo lo
conoce a usted y me conoce este pueblo
sabe que a usted no le gusta a los
pobres este pueblo sabe que en campaña
hay gente desesperada para hablar con el
pueblo la compañía electoral de los
comicios más polarizados en décadas
arrancó el pasado martes Y promete ser
una batalla entre estos dos candidatos
favoritos ya que los demás aspirantes se
encuentran muy rezagados un
enfrentamiento entre dos modelos para
Brasil las propuestas socialistas de
Lula por un lado y por el otro el
populismo de derecha de bolsonaro
nuestro país no quiere dar pasos atrás
no queremos ideología de género en las
escuelas nuestro no quiere legalizar las
drogas nuestro país respeta la vida
desde su Concepción nuestro país no
quiere convertirse en un Aliado del
comunismo en otros países el 2 de
octubre la decisión Está en manos de los
más de 156 millones de lectores de
confirmarse las estimaciones el poco
margen entre ambos candidatos llevaría a
los brasileños a una segunda vuelta
en Colombia el presidente Gustavo Petro
decretó la suspensión de las órdenes de
captura contra los miembros del Ln que
están en Cuba las órdenes Fueron
emitidas por el ex presidente Iván Duque
en 2019 de este modo el nuevo mandatario
colombiano quiere reencaminar las
negociaciones de paz con la alegría
suspender órdenes de captura a esos
negociadores
[Música]
suspender órdenes de extradición a esos
negociadores para que comience un
diálogo con el ejército de liberación
nacional así llamado
para intentar construir el camino Ojalá
rápido y Expedito en donde esta
organización
deje de ser una guerrilla insurgente en
Colombia
previamente hablamos con Luis Eduardo
Celis analista de temas de paz y
conflicto armado y asesor de la
fundación paz y Reconciliación en
Colombia nos contó Qué significa esta
suspensión para el avance hacia una paz
negociada con el eln
bueno el anuncio que ha hecho hoy el
presidente Gustavo Petro de levantar las
órdenes de captura y la solicitudes de
extradición y de permitir un re contacto
con de los de la delegación que está en
Cuba con con el lln en su conjunto pues
son pasos procedentes hacia restablecer
una negociación es el camino correcto de
crear las condiciones para ese
entendimiento recordar que el gobierno
anterior colocó nuevamente las órdenes
de captura solicitudes de extradición Y
fue todo un desastre ese esa esa
política Entonces es una muy buena
noticia para restablecer esa negociación
tan importante para la paz de Colombia
vamos a México donde compareció ante la
justicia el ex procurador general Jesús
Murillo Karam encargado de las primeras
investigaciones sobre la masacre de
Ayotzinapa durante el gobierno de Peña
Nieto Murillo fue detenido el viernes
después de que el jueves la comisión de
la verdad describiera el asesinato de
los 43 estudiantes como un crimen de
estado los mexicanos ven con esperanza a
estos movimientos de la justicia Rafael
Pérez nos cuenta más
el caso de los 43 desaparecidos está
cada vez más lejos de cerrar en este
sentido la detención de la ex procurador
general de la república Jesús Murillo
caram genera opiniones diversas los
mexicanos
todos estamos dolidos por esa
desaparición forzada un crimen de estado
que hasta el momento
es impunidad los lo que seguimos viendo
porque es un personaje que se tardó años
en ser detenido pero que además no
resuelve el conflicto de este crimen de
estado Murillo llegó en la mañana de
este sábado al reclusorio norte de la
Ciudad de México donde enfrenta la
primera audiencia por su presunta
participación en la desaparición de los
jóvenes normalistas sentimos que es un
primer paso para que haya justicia para
que se castigue a quienes se cometieron
ese crimen crimen de estado y también
para que se esclarezca lo que sucedió
terrible noche la fiscalía general de la
república dio a conocer además órdenes
de arresto contra 20 militares 44
policías así como a funcionarios
estatales y miembros del Cartel
Guerreros Unidos Pues que hasta ellos
llegue esa esa ese rigor de la ley que
se aplique correctamente no eso sería
algo que creo que todos los mexicanos
Necesitamos saber según la presidencia
del país el ex procurador no opuso
resistencia a su arresto y se mantendrá
detenido en la capital la oposición
política del gobierno ha manifestado que
la captura de Murillo caram responde a
temas políticos
El Papá Francisco y el Vaticano han
guardado silencio tras el arresto del
obispo de matagalpa en Nicaragua Pero la
conferencia episcopal italiana aseguró
que la Iglesia Católica está bajo una
dura persecución en el país
centroamericano según las autoridades el
obispo fue detenido por actividades
desestabilizadoras y provocadoras
Álvarez un fuerte crítico del gobierno
del presidente Daniel Ortega llevaba dos
semanas confinado en una casa de la
diócesis los detalles en el siguiente
informe
dos semanas de encierro culminaron con
la detención del obispo Rolando Álvarez
el viernes por la mañana fue sacado
contra su voluntad de su casa en
matagalpa y trasladado a la capital
Managua 130 kilómetros según las
autoridades se encuentra bajo arresto
domiciliario en la capital la policía
había rodeado su vivienda desde el 4 de
agosto cuando Álvarez había grabado Este
vídeo
he querido salir a la catedral a hacer
la hora santa la santa misa pero
obviamente la autoridad es superiores no
me no han dado permiso nos encontramos
aquí seis sacerdotes seis altos que nos
tienen encerrados en la furia físico
para Aquí vamos a permanecer sin
irrespetar a la policía madre de tu hija
Álvarez es abiertamente crítico del
gobierno del presidente Daniel Ortega y
la relación entre la Iglesia Católica y
el gobierno de Ortega ha sido muy tensa
Desde que la represión de las protestas
contra Ortega en 2018 se saldó con
cientos de muertos para los católicos
este último acontecimiento ha cruzado la
línea la represión y es algo que algo
que está saliendo del límite pues con la
Iglesia Católica en la iglesia estamos
en oración para que todo salga bien para
que lo liberen por lo que ha pasado
usted sabe y
es muy doloroso ver eso ya que el obispo
ha sido muy bueno con todo Ortega
gobernó por primera vez en los años 80
antes de volver en 2007 y desde entonces
ha ganado tres elecciones sucesivas sin
participación de la oposición en las
últimas celebradas en noviembre del año
pasado muchos de los principales rivales
de Ortega fueron encarcelados obligados
a exiliarse según la Unión Europea
Nicaragua tiene más de 180 presos
políticos
y terminamos este noticiero en Panamá
donde la cultura afrocolonial se tomó
las calles de portobelo en la provincia
de Colón el festival de La pollera Congo
celebra la mujer afro y cimarrona con el
objetivo de conmemorar la cultura Congo
desde la época de la esclavitud este
festival tiene lugar cada dos años en el
país centroamericano
[Música]
y así llegamos al fin de esta edición
pero sigan con nosotros en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]